parlant de situation brûlante ou de
controverses brûlantes parlons de la loi
96 sur la protection du français elle
est appliquée la loi et ça provoque des
situations qui soulèvent des questions
dorénavant pour obtenir des services en
anglais certaines personnes doivent
déclarer de bonnes foi qu'elles ont
droit à des services en anglais au
Québec qui sont les gens qui ont droit à
des services en anglais ce qu'on appelle
les ayants droits disons la minorité
anglophone traditionnelle donc des
Québécois anglophones de souche appelé
comme ça pour
aller à la plus simple expression des
immigrants qui sont au Québec depuis
moins de 6 mois des gens qui sont non
résidents et des autochtones tous ces
gens-là ont le droit d'avoir un service
en anglais s'ils appellent un service
gouvernemental ils veulent des services
en anglais ils doivent par exemple peser
sur le 2 en déclarant de bonne foi
qu'ils y en droit la ville de
Côte-Saint-Luc les amis appliquent la
loi avec une touche de sarcasme on
écoute
ville de Côte-Saint-Luc pour continuer
en français appuyez sur 1 et puis voir
c'est comme ça que ça marche ici à côté
pas besoin de présenter un bulletin
scolaire votre arbre généalogique des 10
générations précédentes ou encore de
nous promettre quoi que ce soit Michel
c'est exemple étant mis à part de façon
générale vous trouvez ça insultant si
j'ai bien compris ce que vous avez dit
vendredi à la radio pour la minorité
anglophone cette façon de faire du
gouvernement du
québecable à de bonnes mesures pour
stopper le déclin de la langue française
et favoriser l'utilisation de la langue
française comme par exemple la ministre
Fréchette contre le faire en ce qui
concerne les nouveaux arrivants
je dirais que mon indignation se traduit
face à la communauté anglophone qui est
ici depuis toujours de génération en
génération et je ne vois pas pourquoi il
faudrait que cette communauté là que ce
soit de bonne foi je veux bien
et même à dire qu'ils sont des
anglophones de souche et que de bonne
foi ils ont droit au service en anglais
c'est ça que je trouve
je trouve que ça va beaucoup trop loin
dans ce sens-là et que ce n'est pas une
question de respect par rapport à cette
communauté là qui a effectivement ses
droits-là je sais de comprendre en
premièrement comment cette mesure là va
être vraiment opérante quelle sorte de
résultat qu'elle va effectivement donner
quand l'objectif est effectivement de
pouvoir favoriser la langue française et
et à partir du moment où cette mesure-là
s'applique pas de façon comment dire
strict
qu'on fasse confiance de toute façon il
y a déjà une porte passion d'anglophone
là je parle j'ai l'impression que le
gouvernement il fait ça davantage pour
les allophones pour les nouveaux
arrivants et ça
dans les six mois après leur arrivée en
principe ils doivent communiquer avec le
gouvernement en français mais à partir
du moment Sébastien où les nouvelles
règles de la ministrechette c'est de
dire que tous les nouveaux arrivants
économiques par exemple doivent parler
français à ce moment-là pourquoi faut-il
demander à la communauté anglophone je
répète qui est là depuis toujours de
génération génération de dire de bonne
foi qui sont de la communauté là vous
allez me dire qu'est-ce que c'est pas si
grave que ça puis Jean-François en
parlera tantôt pour lui c'est pas si
grave que ça pour moi c'est une question
de principe c'est une question de
respect ils ont des droits et à ce
moment-là qu'on les reconnaisse d'emblée
et puis qu'on n'est pas besoin de faire
cette mise en garde cela dit je dois pas
aussi loin que côté
c'est pas nécessaire non plus alors tout
ce que ça fait ça augmente les
frustrations les frustrations notamment
de la communauté francophone anglophone
et
pourquoi ça favorise de mieux vivre
ensemble de ces deux communautés et je
le termine je répète je parle pas des
nouveaux arrivants je parle pas de ceux
qui sont issus de l'immigration je parle
de ces communautés là ça m'apparaît
superflu non nécessaire inopérant et
qu'on vive dans leur respect des deux
communautés au Québec avec les lois qui
existent et les règles qui existent au
téléphone c'était lequel c'est à dire
que les gens sont seuls avec leur
téléphone puis ils pèsent sur deux ou
ils peuvent pas sur deux comptoir à
Longueuil au comptoir il va se passer
quoi
même pas la version anglaise sur leur
site et qu'on leur dit d'aller vers la
traduction Google encore une fois pour
des anglophones qui sont là depuis
toujours si je trouve ça exagéré et et
et
inutile et comment ça va se passer au
comptoir ce sera à voir ce sera à suivre
ils ont des droits que leurs droits
soient respectés
devant un nouvel arrivant êtes-vous un
anglophone de souche minorité historique
ok Dimitri
je pense qu'il faut il faut retourner à
la case de départ et l'objectif est
simple l'objectif c'est que le français
est la langue officielle du Québec et la
langue commune mais en même temps il y a
un objectif secondaire et cet objectif
secondaire c'est par exemple les
générations qui nous suivent les plus
jeunes derrière nous on va on veut que
ces gens-là soient parfaitement
bilingues quand en anglais qu'en
français encore une fois c'est ça
l'avantage compétitif du Québec
c'est une bonne chose de demander est-ce
que c'est une bonne chose de demander
aux gens de bonne foi de dire s'ils ont
droit à des services en anglais ou pas
selon vous honnêtement je ne pense pas
que c'est là où cette bataille va se
gagner c'est-à-dire quand tu vas au
guichet et tu ne parles pas français et
on te dit ben tu fais pas partie des
catégories donc on peut pas te servir je
pense qu'il ne faut pas manquer
l'objectif et deuxièmement je suis allé
sur le site Web du gouvernement du
Québec aujourd'hui
le site Web du gouvernement du Québec
est en anglais aussi il n'est pas
uniquement en français donc les bonnes
mesures sont les bonnes mesures mais de
dire à quelqu'un tu dois fitter dans une
catégorie de X et Y Z pour qu'on puisse
te parler en anglais l'objectif c'est de
parler français d'employer la langue
française comme la langue principale la
langue commune mais de dire à quelqu'un
au guichet automobile au guichet de la
Ville de Longueuil par exemple on peut
pas te parler va sur google je pense que
c'est contre-productif d'accord
Jean-François
ce serait contre-productif mais c'est
absolument pas la mesure ce qui va se
passer au guichet c'est que la personne
anglophone va dire en anglais bonjour
moi j'ai le droit des services en
anglais alors je vais les avoir puis la
personne veut dire oui c'est la règle si
vous dites de bonne foi vous aviez droit
vous y avez droit puis on vérifie pas
c'est comme ça c'est la politique qui a
annoncé Monsieur Robert
non c'est non on peut même penser que il
devrait au moins dire qu'il y aura des
vérifications aléatoires au cas où c'est
une fois de temps en temps mais alors à
quoi ça sert d'abord les anglophones ont
le droit à l'école anglaise mais il ne
se présente pas à la Commission scolaire
ou à l'école en disant ben moi j'y ai
droit mon enfant il a droit non il lui
demande de montrer ses papiers alors
déjà pour avoir son droit à l'école il
doit faire cette démonstration là ce qui
est beaucoup plus sévère que ce qui est
proposé maintenant
et c'est une mesure qui protège
totalement les droits acquis on dit tous
ceux qui ont le droit vous avez juste à
le dire alors à qui est-ce que ça
profite en ce moment au Québec la
situation jusqu'à la semaine dernière
c'était c'est le bilinguisme
institutionnel tout le monde le libre
choix d'avoir des services
gouvernementaux en français ou en
anglais et donc le signal qu'on envoie à
tout le monde c'est qu'ici il y a deux
langues communes pour les services
publics c'est les deux langues alors
c'est le contraire du signal qu'on
voulait envoyer et là maintenant on
envoie le signal qui a écouté il y a une
langue commune c'est le français mais il
y a des gens qui ont le droit d'avoir
l'anglais eux à eux en deux alors on va
dire ben oui mais comme c'est juste de
bonne foi les gens vont frauder il y
aura toujours des gens qui vont frauder
mais je vais vous dire une chose quel
que soit la loi ou le règlement
l'immense majorité des citoyens se
conformes aux lois et aux règlements et
c'est encore plus vrai pour la
population immigrante qui est toujours
un peu plus craintive que les autres
c'est évident que le nombre de personnes
francophones
va aller va être beaucoup plus restreint
et que dans ce sens là ici je le répète
c'est c'est les droits fondamentaux de
ces deux communautés c'est tout ce que
je dis là et dans ce sens là c'est juste
d'avoir à le dire c'est juste ça mon
point je suis pas désaccord avec le fait
que le français la langue commune
comprenant nous bien mais jusqu'à
maintenant je pense que ces gens-là qui
sont je le répète
majoritairement bilingue et ça j'ai
vérifié ce matin les chiffres sont très
clairs sont mal alors c'est pas parce
que ils ont de la difficulté à parler
français moi je veux juste qu'on
respecte qui ils sont et que dans ce
sens là il n'est pas à répondre à aucune
question par par rapport à ça
pourquoi ils doivent montrer des papiers
à l'époque différents Jean-François
l'école c'est non pour moi l'école c'est
super important tout à fait d'accord
avec la loi 101 pourquoi parce que tu
dis pendant 15 ans au moins et que là il
faut effectivement qu'on soit capable
d'avoir un enseignement en français pour
ceux qui ont le droit puis en anglais
pour ceux qui ont droit là on parle de
quelqu'un qui va chercher un permis de
construction par exemple à la Ville de
Longueuil ou quelqu'un qui appelle le 3
1 1 à la Ville de Montréal pour un
renseignement très
quotidien disons c'est bien différent du
système d'éducation c'est très
très différents notre système
d'éducation d'étudie pendant pendant
justifier de quoi comment mais
explique-moi si on fait pas ça comment
est-ce que tu vas faire en sorte pour
dire à tous les non en anglophones qui
peuvent pas demander des services en
anglais comment tu vas faire ça et voilà
c'est ça qui me choque un peu
Jean-François c'est qu'on fait on fait
porter le fardeau à la communauté
anglophone pour les tous ceux qui
arrivent au Québec et c'est là où moi je
dis puis ça va prendre plus de temps
Jean-François mais c'est là où je dis ou
la mesure de la ministre Fréchette et la
bonne mesure je te donne raison parce
que tu
comparais toujours avec l'Angleterre le
Royaume-Uni il faut qu'on parle anglais
ils t'ont écouté et finalement je je
conviens que c'est probablement la bonne
chose à faire de dire quand vous arrivez
aux travailleurs économiques vous devez
parler français alors là c'est clair
pour tout le monde c'est clair pour tout
le monde c'est on sait dans quoi on
s'embarque avant de vouloir venir au
Québec et ça règle la question
comment veux-tu pour enlever le signal
qu'il y a deux langues communes au
Québec pour tous les services
gouvernementaux le français et l'anglais
et envoyer le signal qui en a seulement
une si c'est pas la façon qui est faite
depuis le 1er juin mais c'est parce que
le signal Jean-François il est là il est
clair le signal il est clair dans les
documents gouvernementaux il est clair
quand on veut venir au Québec il est
clair dans l'ensemble de la
documentation qui est fournit à tous ces
gens là je veux dire un moment donné
c'est là où je dis que ça va trop loin
quand on est arrivé au service
téléphonique un service téléphonique
pour des gens qui demandent des services
en anglais alors qu'il nous disent que
94% des gens qui parlent français mais
beaucoup plus de gens qui demandent des
services en anglais année après année
alors c'est pas vrai que tout le monde
ait compris
françoise est au comptoir depuis un bout
de temps donc on va lui donner la parole
en anglais pour avoir la parole
hello bonjour
pour commencer une petite parenthèse ici
on parle de service gouvernementaux
municipaux provinciaux et c'est pas
d'habitude quand on appelle par exemple
une municipalité ou lorsqu'on appelle un
service gouvernemental par exemple
Revenu Québec ou autre c'est pas des
petits dossiers là alors c'est bien
important que les gens puissent
comprendre l'information qui leur est
donné et ils sont autant en français en
passant qu'en anglais parce que des fois
je me suis trouvé avec des préposés qui
me parlaient en français puis je peux
convaincu que je comprenais ce qui me
disait et c'est pour moi le qui suit
obstuce là-dessus il y a une différence
pour moi par rapport en fait oui et non
pas vraiment une différence entre
l'école le fait que les
anglophone de souche si on veut prendre
l'expression sont habitués de démontrer
qu'ils ont droit aux services scolaire
et de faire le même genre poser le même
genre de geste dans les dans le cadre de
d'autres services parce que
une influence à une incidence sur le
nombre de préposés qu'on va avoir au
service etc alors si tout le monde c'est
à peu près à lavabovite puis n'importe
qui peut avoir n'importe quel service
ben je pense qu'on va manquer on va
manquer notre coup là dessus mais mon
dieu que ça a été mal communiqué et de
voir des municipalités comme
Côte-Saint-Luc par exemple
démontrer le peu de lit deux chiffres
qu'il devrait avoir là dessus si t'es
pas d'accord avec quelque chose
démonte-le de d'autres façons que de
rire parce que ce que tu envoies comme
message à tous tes citoyens
municipalité c'est qu'on peut rire de
certaines lois de nous on le fait alors
qu'est-ce qui m'empêcherait moi comme
citoyenne de cette municipalité là qui
aime peut-être pas la réglementation en
matière de je sais pas moi de
stationnement de rire d'en face de la
municipalité parce que c'est le message
qu'ils ont envoyé par ailleurs je pense
que le fait qu'on va se fier beaucoup à
la bonne foi des gens ça devrait limiter
les choses quand je vois dans le reste
du pays en passant qui pense qu'on est
tous une gang de
anti-anglophone au Québec puis que ah il
devrait peut-être aux autres avoir une
loi qui dit tout leur service vont être
en anglais ben amusez-vous les amis
parce que c'est ça dans vos provinces
alors ça nous fera pas un Grand Prix sur
la différence vous pouvez vous déclarer
une élingue anglophone c'est fait depuis
des lunes au cosu que vous ne le saviez
pas alors est-ce que ça va changer grand
chose je suis pas si certaines que ça et
je pense malgré tout que quand on joue
avec des dossiers
[Musique]
fragiliser des gens de tomber en amour
de la même façon que je suis tombé en
amour avec la langue française
juste
que ce soit la loi 101 l'école les
enfants qui doivent aller à l'école en
français c'est d'une certaine façon au
coercitive bon ils ont pas le choix mais
c'était pourri mais mais c'était
coercitif pour ma mère qui n'avait pas
d'autre choix que de m'envoyer à une
école francophone française mais pour
moi quand je regarde en arrière je dis
c'est la meilleure expérience de ma vie
et si j'aurais à prendre cette décision
10 fois sur 10 je choisirais mais encore
une fois vous l'auriez peut-être pas
prise la décision maintenant mais mais
mais là sur la langue française et sur
l'éducation c'est important mais se
servir au guichet pour avoir un permis
pour mettre une piscine dans ta cour
arrière ou pour avoir un permis pour
pour stationner ton auto sur ta rue
franchement c'est c'est je suis un
fervent défenseur de française je suis
un fervent défenseur de l'importance que
cette langue française puisse s'épanouir
au Québec et dans le reste du Canada
tout ce que je dis c'est forcé les plus
jeunes générations ou aller à l'école
quand elle est à l'école quel ordre
l'angle à prendre ça va voir
potentiellement un impact
adverse encore une fois on veut notre
objectif devrait être que nos jeunes les
générations derrière nous soient
parfaitement bilingues tant en anglais
qu'en français ça ne veut pas dire parce
que tu parles anglais que tu n'es pas
capable de maîtriser ta langue
maternelle ou la langue française
je conclus qu'est-ce qu'on dit en
immigrants après 7 mois non
tes premiers six mois on peut te servir
en anglais 7e
ta flaque mon ami puis d'apprendre le
français pour un allophone en 6 mois
bonne chance c'est c'est des cours en
accéléré ok Jean-François là c'est
vraiment la conclusion Jean-François oui
j'aimerais beaucoup ça que l'État
allemand ou japonais ou chinois me
laisse six mois en français avant de
passer à la langue nationale mais j'ai
pas l'impression qu'ils vont faire ça
mais je vais seulement dire une chose
c'est que une étude sur les jeunes de
l'office de langue française qui a fait
3000 entrevues un an que démontré que
les francophones qui vont au cégep
anglophone
préfèrent dans une grande proportion
avoir des services en anglais
alors eux on va leur dire si vous n'êtes
pas un ail endroit vous l'aurez pas et
ça c'est le déclin et la langue
française est tellement fort il faut
appuyer sur chacun des leviers aucun des
leviers seuls n'est suffisant pour
renverser le déclin l'affichage par
exemple prédominant en français c'est
pas suffisant c'est la totalité des
efforts qui pourraient nous permettre de
renverser le déclin dans cette mesure
d'accord pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI